l'armée chinoise est entré dans pékin il
y à une heure des milliers de soldats
sont aux armes avance vers la place
tienanmen bourré de manifestants
élection historique dimanche en pologne
le premier scrutin neigeux s'est dit
ouvert à l'opposition favoriserait
solidarité aux dépens du régime semaine
folle à moscou au congrès des députés du
peuple les nouveaux élus malmène la
langue de bois et tous les tabous de
l'histoire soviétique le rpr emplois ces
cours en séminaire à huis clos demain
pour ressouder le mouvement sous la
houlette de jacques chirac
roland garros où la pluie une bonne
partie de la journée quelques rencontres
entre les gouttes
voilà monsieur bon soit il y à une heure
à pk l'armée a fait son entrée dans le
centre de la ville il est 3 heures du
matin là bas des milliers de soldats
sont en train d'avancer sans armes
apparentes en tout cas vers la place
tienanmen
après des semaines de contestation à
ciel ouvert le régime semble donc passer
à l'offensive
plus tôt dans la soirée malgré la loi
martiale des centaines de milliers de
manifestants s'étaient massés à nouveau
place tiananmen pour soutenir quatre
protestataires qui avaient commencé une
grève de la faim contre cette loi
martiale
quelle est la situation exacte à pékin
le point par téléphone avec bruno
l'adresse l'armée populaire de
libération chinoise vient donc de
pénétrer dans le centre de pékin
alors que les étudiants occupent la
place tienanmen depuis près de trois
semaines
une intervention qui a immédiatement
mobilisé la population de la ville
depuis l'endroit où je me trouve je vois
des milliers peut-être des centaines de
milliers de personnes se précipiter vers
la place des naines à bicyclette ou à
pied
les soldats ne semblent pas armés ils se
sont dirigés en défilant verte et mad
men et la troisième fois en deux jours
que l'on voit des soldats en uniforme
dans le centre de la capitale chinoise
hier le journal de l'armée nationale
populaire publié d'ailleurs des photos
en indiquant que 150000 à 200000 hommes
de trond
je tenais préfère appliquer la loi
martiale qui avait été décrétée il ya
exactement une semaine et un jour par le
premier ministre li peng
oui s'il ya donc du nouveau à pékin dans
la demi-heure qui vient bruno le dreff
c'est fort sera sûrement de nous
rappeler tout arrive à l'est même un
début de pratique démocratique en
pologne dimanche prochain aura lieu le
premier tour d'élections législatives
sans précédent pour la première fois
dans un régime communiste elles sont
ouvertes à l'opposition
le scrutin ne sera que partiellement
libres pour la diète puisque
l'opposition y sera limitée quel que
soit son score à prendre 5 % des mandats
mais le sénat lui sera librement élu les
candidats du pouvoir et ceux de
solidarité s'affrontent dans une
campagne courtoise mais passionné qui
semble tourner à l'avantagé des
partisans de valises à sur place un peu
l'homme jacques berline ou assis vient
candidats de chaque camp bin houye anas
a pour sa petite fille une infection
particulière c'est pour elle qu'il a mis
fin à trois années de clandestinité
prenant le risque d'aller en prison car
chef ouvrier électricien il fut l'un des
fondateurs de solidarité et est
aujourd'hui qu'en dit la députée à
varsovie
grégory de derek se présente lui aussi
pour la première fois des élections
candidat présenté par le parti
communiste dont il est membre depuis 23
ans il se lance dans la bataille sans
état d'âme directeur général d'une
entreprise
il dispose de tous les avantages de sa
position
deux âmes de campagne aux styles bien
différents le candidat le soldat nash
fait deux ou trois mille team car jours
allant dans les coins les plus reculés
de sa circonscription sur des estrades
improvisé il s'efforce d'abord de lutter
contre l'abstention et temps ensuite de
persuader ses auditeurs que le chemin
vers la démocratie est ouvert mais qu'il
faut rester vigilant une volonté qui
parfois se heurte à beaucoup de méfiance
tout ça c'est bien beau 17,1 mais qu'est
ce qui nous garantit qui après les
élections il n'y aura pas de nouveau la
loi martiale le candidat de la coalition
gouvernementale si prend autres morts
pour séduire ses électeurs il fait appel
à des clowns pour attirer les familles
distribuer stylo hebbadj et explique
qu'il est bien placé pour rendre de
nombreux services à côté de lui un
candidat communiste au sénat n'hésite
pas à utiliser les couleurs du drapeau
américain et la photo de georges bush
pour convaincre de son ouverture et de
sa modernité modernité c'est le maître
mot de grégory tout derek un auditoire
clairsemé
il vante ses qualités de gestionnaire
évitant soigneusement tout sujet
véritablement politique même si parfois
on le contredit assez vigoureusement
vous dites que votre entreprise fait des
bénéfices mais en vérité vous vivez avec
les subventions de l'état soutient c'est
à quelle est aujourd'hui la différence
essentielle entre un communiste et un
membre de solidarnosc
il y avait une différence car ils sont
tous les deux polonais en ce qui
concerne les programmes se ressemblent
beaucoup
ils sont presque semblable des cobayes
il y a simplement des différents
approche ou de choix d'actions à
entreprendre
est ce que vous pensez il y aller bon
communiste les communistes je les ai pas
rencontré et je ne sais pas ce que c'est
qu'un vrai communisme ici le plaisir que
des communistes issus de l'époque
stalinienne
peta qui vivent aux antilles et c'est
vrai que dans cette campagne électorale
la première entièrement libre depuis
plus de 40 ans chacun retient ses coûts
l'opposition n'utilise pas les arguments
de corruption d'incompétence à l'égard
du pouvoir
le pouvoir lui même ne souligne pas
toutes les ambiguïtés du mouvement
solidarnosc
c'est que de part et d'autre on sait que
pour quelques années encore on a besoin
de l'autre même sur le bébé est en union
soviétique la vie collective et les
conversations sont véritablement
suspendu depuis plusieurs jours aux
débats du congrès des députés du peuple
des propos invraisemblables avant les
dernières élections ayant été tenue qui
remettent en cause quelques-uns des
dogmes ou des piliers du système comme
le kgb qui bouscule les tabous un député
a même demandé que la dépouille de
lénine quittent la place rouge et une
commission d' enquête parlementaire
vient d'être créée sur quoi sur l'accord
secret conclu entre hitler et staline
pour se partager leurs offres michel
mompontet depuis une semaine en direct à
la télévision
200 millions de soviétiques assists
éberlué au plus formidable des
feuilletons qui leur ait jamais été
donné de voir toutes liées
rebondissements trahison manoeuvre
découvertes surprises et heureux
dénouement
les dallas et dynastie de l'ouest sont
battus à plate couture
mais ici en plus le spectacle est à
l'échelle de l'état un état gigantesque
qui semble réapprendre son histoire et
découvrir le goût spécial de la
démocratie mes personnages
mikhaïl gorbatchev or maître d'école qui
tentent de se faire entendre
face à lui deux mille deux cent
cinquante députés fraîchement élus tout
aussi turbulent que leurs confrères de
l'ouest pourquoi c'est toujours les
mêmes qui parlent ici
moi je viens de lituanie et c'est pas
pour rien j'espère mais il livre répond
gorbatchev que ceux qui veulent prendre
la parole lev un papier blanc pour
commencer bien ça commençait bien
c'est durant toute la semaine dans un
formidable déballage les tabous les plus
sacrées l'union soviétique vont voler en
éclats le kgb trop de pouvoir les
nationalités et tous fait l'armée trop
coûteuse mallarmé notre éducation en
faillite depuis vingt ans rien est
épargné pas même l'histoire staline et
hitler ont pactisé sur le dos des pays
baltes en trente neuf
enfin la dépouille de lénine doit être
enlevé du mausolée de la place rouge
rien de moins
c'était en direct une semaine de
psychanalyse à l'échelle d'un état après
la chine la pologne l'union soviétique
l'histoire qui bouge ainsi à l'est
arrêtons nous maintenant sur l'histoire
d'une femme il y a des vies comme ça que
l'actualité ballet brutalement pour les
oublier aussitôt et qui ressemble à de
mauvais mais l'eau ainsi jocelyne
ceccarelli c'est une femme de 23 ans en
prison depuis hier soupçonné d'avoir
voulu tuer son enfant qu'elle prétendait
disparu jocelyne a été abandonnée à la
naissance c'est une enfant de la dass
adopté à l'âge de 13 ans soignée aux
neuroleptiques après une grave
dépression et victimes il y a quelques
mois d'une tentative de viol elle aurait
voulu se débarrasser de son petit garçon
pour blesser son mari patrice blais a
rencontré sa mère adoptive qui tentent
de comprendre
jocelyne ceccarelli n'est pas née du bon
côté des choses adopté à 13 ans une
enfance de nourrice en centre spécialisé
de médecins en neurologue toujours à la
recherche de son équilibre psychologique
une grossesse très difficile six mois
alité une tentative de viol il ya moins
d'un an
trop plein de malheur pour jocelyne dans
sa famille personne ne comprend son acte
mais personne ne la juge dans un état
effroyable
parce qu'elle se culpabiliser
et là je ce dont je suis sûr c'est que
un peu n'importe quoi lui demander pour
se culpabiliser pour se punir elle dira
oui je sais pas ce que les policiers lui
ont demandé mais je suis sûr si l'on
demande est ce si cela est ce que vous
l'avez fait oui est ce que vous avez
voulu tuer l'enfant oui j'ai voulu le
tuer elle avait en véritable crise et
c'est pourquoi je comprends très bien
que ce qu'elle ne soit pas prêt d
enfants et c'est pas moi qui même si
elle était libérée ou autre qui lui
donnerait les enfants - ça parce qu'on
les aime ces poupons et on trouve
qu'elle ne peut pas s'en occuper ça y'a
aucun doute là dessus on lui remettrait
pas entre les mains mais par contre elle
elle a besoin d'être soigné
c'est des bulles sur mais elle était
normal elle avait manqué d'affection
étaient avides d'affection à voulait
qu'on l'ait mais voulait donner beaucoup
d'amour
les ceccarelli un couple tranquille au
moins pour les voisins mais une vie
perturbée par les troubles psychiques de
jocelyne pourtant elle faisait tout pour
ses enfants affirme la famille
alors pourquoi l'abandon de raphaël
c'était le préféré de mon mari aurait
confié la jeune mère aux policiers
toujours en observation à l'hôpital
l'enfant fera l'objet d'une décision de
justice
comme sa soeur béatrice lagarde au père
si celui-ci s'engage à les séparer de
leur mère ou alors un placement auprès
de l'assistance publique le financement
des partis politiques à nouveau sur le
métier le premier ministre demande au
ministre de l'intérieur d'étudier un
avant projet de loi sur la question qui
sera discuté selon les termes de sa
lettre en dehors de tout contexte
électoral à l'assemblée nationale le
débat sur le projet de loi joxe sur
l'immigration a repris lentement le rpr
et l'opposition ont choisi la tactique
de l'enlisement y vite à leur tour par
les socialistes et les communistes qui
était totalement absente une partie de
l'après-midi le rpr par et au fil des
semaines tiraillé entre des courants
divergents il ya les rénovateurs les
réformateurs les régulateurs de quoi y
perdre le sens de l'ordre et de la
discipline pourtant traditionnels dans
le mouvement demain à huis clos jacques
chirac réunit un séminaire
10 de réflexion objectif resserrer les
boulons et répondre aux inquiétudes des
militants de base qui sont un peu
perplexe comme ce que laurent bousses ya
rencontré dans deux fédérations dans la
sarthe et en seine-saint-denis
réformateur rénovateurs transcourants au
rpr l'écart se creuse entre ceux qui
voudraient voir le parti gaulliste
redevenir un grand rassemblement
populaire de droite et ceux qui se
sentent plus proches d'un libéralisme
centriste un écart idéologique doublé
d'un écart géographique
c'est ici en région parisienne que l'on
rencontre le plus grand nombre de
députés et de militants partisans d'une
ligne dure pour eux le consensus mou ça
suffit il faut qu'on relance le rpr il
faut que l'on fasse repartir
l'opposition qu'on l'occurrence on est
tous derrière chirac qu'il faudrait
donner des vitamines un chien qui c'est
vrai c'est charles pasqua qui l'a dit
c'est pas parce qu'il ya pas de majorité
qu'il faut paquet d'opposition quant aux
rénovateurs
moi je suis comme la plupart des
français je les ai déjà oublié fort à
mesure on se demande si ces hommes ne
sont pas en train de jouer un jeu
personnel plutôt que d'essayer de marché
tous dans le même sens derrière chirac
à l'autre bout de la galaxie gaulliste
le plus souvent en province les
rénovateurs se pose des questions
s'ils refusent pour le moment l'idée de
scission on peut se demander comment ils
se sentent à l'intérieur du parti plutôt
mal leur père est en crise
il cherche sa son orientation
il a beaucoup changé par rapport à ce
que ce qui était à l'origine nous
essayons différentes entre des voies
différentes
les habitudes pour le moment permettent
difficilement cette ouverture cet
affrontement de tendance
nous essayons donc de travailler à la
réforme du mouvement
pour le moment c'est assez difficile je
dirais que je me sentirai mieux si le
rpr s'ouvrait un peu plus il faudrait
des statuts beaucoup plus souples qui
permettent à chacun de s'exprimer en
fonction d'eux
de ces de ces différentes tendances
justement pour éviter les cassures
jacques chirac devra demain faire la
synthèse de toutes ces tendances
il peut y arriver à condition d'avoir
enfin digéré son échec aux dernières
présidentielles élections européennes
clôturent ce sport du dépôt des
candidatures 15 listes s'affronteront
finalement pour les principales d'entre
elles le dernier sondage ipsos/le point
donnent les listes fabius et giscard à
égalité à 27% légère baisse donc pour la
liste socialiste hausse pour la liste
l'ancien président selon ce même sondage
la liste des verts avec 13% dépasserait
d'un point la liste de simone veil avec
12% 11% encore pour le front national et
6 % pour la liste communiste au centre
madame simone veil continue de faire
campagne avec entrain véronique synthé
livre l'a suivi en bretagne et en
charente aujourd'hui 6 heures du matin à
la criée de saint guénolé
le cours du baril remonte le cours du
baril baisse
simone veil elle aime tous les poissons
pourvu qu'ils soient frais tout au long
de sa journée en bretagne la tête de
liste centriste c'est oxygénée de l'air
du temps et des sondages favorables
elle n'a pas peur du flux et du reflux
elle pêche en eau profonde
hors des structures politiques dans un
électorat éparpillés il ya un certain
nombre d'électeurs qui sont au fond un
peu hésitant qui ne savent pas très bien
où ils se situent les sondages le mans
et qu'une seule liste de l'opposition
qui se présente comme une liste de
droite ne capterait pas cet électorat à
portsall là où l'amoco cadiz et échoué
il ya 11 ans simone veil parle de
l'environnement pour elle un combat pour
l'avenir de l'humanité qu'elle souhaite
mener avec tous en vendée simone veil
par l'agriculture et quotas laitiers
on interpelle elle répond toujours sur
le fond et les poseurs de questions se
fatiguent toujours les premiers pierre
méhaignerie mais lui aussi la main à la
pâte
valéry giscard d'estaing et alain juppé
qui accusent la liste centriste de
division l'union pour moi je la vois
demain non pas construite sur le sable
des ambitions personnelles de tel ou tel
mais sur l'europe du courage et du
renouveau de la vie politique française
et de l'opposition
simone veil continue une campagne
sereine sans surprise et chacun la
trouve là où il l'attend ce soir comme
tous les vendredis coup de projecteur
sur un candidat hors norme entendait or
carrière politique classique ce soir un
homme qui fit longtemps partie de la
grande muette conseiller de deux
présidents le général jeannou lacaze en
septième position sur la liste vis car
laurent boussier 1985 le général lacaze
chef d'état-major des armées participent
à son dernier grand défilé en compagnie
de françois mitterrand 1989 jeannou
lacaze colistiers de valérie giscard
d'estaing pour les élections européennes
vient faire campagne à poitiers placé en
septième position sur la liste udf rpr
il est pratiquement assuré d'être élu
député européen entre le militaire qui a
passé 45 ans au service de la défense et
l'homme politique qui apparaît une
décision mûrement réfléchie
j'ai toujours été un européen convaincu
et lorsque le président giscard
d'estaing la contacter vont me demander
si j'étais d'accord pour être inscrit
sur sa liste et m'occuper plus
spécialement des problèmes de la dépense
j'ai estimé que ce serait intéressant
pour moi de le prendre cet échelon entre
1985 et 1989 cet homme qui a gardé de
son passage dans les services de
renseignement le goût du secret aura été
le conseiller spécial de quatre
ministres de la défense
grand spécialiste de l'afrique il est à
l'origine des récentes déclarations de
giscard sur l'armée de métier
a strasbourg il s'occupera évidemment
des problèmes de défense européenne mais
il compte bien ne pas se limiter à ce
dossier
à quoi je suis très attaché c'est le
problème
l'environnement dans la défense de la
nature et même la défense des animaux
car j'estime qu'il ya là un véritable
problème
libéré depuis 48 heures du devoir de
réserve celui que l'on appelait le
sphinx apprend aujourd'hui la politique
un métier ou à l inverse de ce qu'il a
fait pendant 45 ans il lui faudra
beaucoup parler et pour parler de
l'europe plus concrètement éloignons
nous de la campagne et retournant à
l'école une école un peu particulière
collège en banlieue parisienne où
fonctionne une classe de 6ème intitulé
sixième européenne
c'est une classe où on étudie l'anglais
l'allemand et l'espagnol
patrick rey cela aille qu'annecy a
policeman 1 donne les vins l'autre
quillot
il espère itunes heroes muthaffar
jean-patrick est déjà à sa manière un
européen à 12 ans à peine sorti de
l'école primaire il étudie comme tous
les élèves de sa classe
l'anglais mais aussi l'allemand et
l'espagnol toute la classe participe
les enfants sont très motivés j'aimerais
bien faire comme et y interprète ou
journalistes et ce sont des métiers en
rapport avec les lents à prendre trois
langues sauf plus de débouchés vendre et
c'est bien mais il faut connaître
d'autres lan 6 heures de langue par
semaine mais également une heure de
cours sur les états membres de la
communauté
la vie des gens les coutumes les rythmes
scolaires à l'étranger sans oublier un
voyage d'étude dans chacun des trois
pays une véritable culture européenne
à cette enseigne en particulier s'ajoute
bien sûr toutes les matières du
programme de 6,5 par an je me suis
aperçu qu'il avait quand même beaucoup
plus de travail qu'une que des camarades
qui sont en 6e normal mais par contre
ça lui plaît beaucoup et ça lui donne le
goût des voyages et des connaissances
des autres pays pour nos enfants
compte tenu de l'ouverture des
frontières en 92
je crois c'est une très grande chance
actuellement sur les 29 élèves en fin de
6e deux seulement ont quelques
difficultés à suivre dans deux ans au
programme une quatrième langue
un exemple d'avant-garde sachant qu'en
france neuf élèves sur dix font de
l'anglais en première langue et certains
n'en apprendrons pas d'autres pas de
chasse aux sorcières à la tête des
sociétés nationalisées
les mandats des présidents arrivent à
échéance il semble que les changements
seront finalement assez limité et est
allé dans le temps claire chazal heureux
et serein
ces pdg ont la confiance du pouvoir et
seront à coup sûr reconduit pour trois
ans jean peyrelevade d'abord patron de
l'uap et un ami politique mais aussi un
président indépendant et efficace
rené thomas ensuite le pdg de la bnp
proche du parti socialiste ou encore
jean gandois qui sort finalement indemne
du rachat de l'américain triangle par
son entreprise péchiney
certains patrons a revanche en dut se
cramponnait à leur fauteuil mais il
devrait finalement le conserver
michel albert aux agf alain gomez chez
thomson à qui l'on reproche sa
participation à la sphère pechiney mais
aussi les libéraux jean rené fourtou qui
garderait rhône poulenc malgré son
attachement passé à la privatisation ou
françois helbronner patron du gan qui a
su récemment donné quelques gages sur la
société générale
les pdg malheureux seront finalement
assez peu nombreux jean saint geours
vient d'abandonner le cic et michel
becker a laissé la place à loïc le floch
prigent à la tête d'elf aquitaine se
sont surtout dans les états majors des
petites banques que l'on pourrait
souffrir à la marseillaise de crédit ou
encore à la banque hervé le président
mitterrand a inauguré cet après midi à
paris le nouveau siège de la mutualité
française
l'occasion de rendre hommage à l'action
des mutualistes et de souligner aussi la
priorité de l'europe sociale anne
consigny
solidarité et heureux les deux
principaux thèmes abordés cet après midi
par françois mitterrand à la mi temps
arrive à échéance
mais il semble que les changements
seront finalement assez limité et est
allé dans le temps claire chazal heureux
et serein ces pdg en la confiance du
pouvoir et seront à coup sûr reconduit
pour trois ans jean peyrelevade d'abord
patron de l'uap et un ami politique mais
aussi un président indépendant et
efficace
rené thomas ensuite le pdg de la bnp
proche du parti socialiste ou encore
jean gandois qui sort finalement indemne
du rachat de l'américain triangle par
son entreprise péchiney
certains patrons a revanche en dut se
cramponner à leur fauteuil mais il
devrait finalement le conserver
michel albert aux agf alain gomez chez
thomson à qui l'on reproche sa
participation à la sphère pechiney mais
aussi les libéraux jean rené fourtou qui
garderait rhône poulenc malgré son
attachement passé à la privatisation ou
françois helbronner patron du gan qui a
su récemment donné quelques gages sur la
société générale
les pdg malheureux seront finalement
assez peu nombreux jean saint geours
vient d'abandonner les cic et michel
becker a laissé la place à loïc le floch
prigent à la tête d'elf aquitaine se
sont surtout dans les états majors des
petites banques que l'on pourrait
souffrir à la marseillaise de crédit ou
encore à la banque hervé le président
mitterrand a inauguré cet après midi à
paris le nouveau siège de la mutualité
française
l'occasion de rendre hommage à l'action
des mutualistes et de souligner aussi la
priorité de l'europe sociale anne
consigny
solidarité et heureux les deux
principaux thèmes abordés cet après midi
par françois mitterrand à la mutualité
française c'était aujourd'hui
l'inauguration de ses nouveaux locaux
situés dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris le président a rendu hommage à
l'oeuvre de solidarité de la mutualité
et tenter de rassurer son président jean
teulade sur la construction de l'europe
sociale
arrivé aujourd'hui à nouméa de louis le
pensec visite de trois jours qui fonde
en pleine campagne électorale régionale
après jacques lafleur aujourd'hui le
ministre des dom tom recevra demain une
délégation pull l'organisation à
laquelle appartenaient les assassins de
jean marie tjibaou et yéwéné yéwéné
voici les premières images de davao
philippines - glissement de terrain a
dévasté mardi dernier une mine d'or
le bilan provisoire fait état de 11
morts mais plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont encore ensevelies 200
logements très précaire abritant des
mineurs et leurs familles ont été
balayés par la coulée de boue
depuis quelques jours heureusement il ya
moins d'agressions signalées dans les
trains et dans le métro mais
l'insécurité demeure dans les têtes
christophe martet et ranger motte ont
suivi l'une des brigades d'intervention
qui patrouillent dans le métro parisien
de vue il faut le dire le carrefour
souterrain de la drogue
leur reportage ligne 9 stations
oberkampf il est 19 heures
un vendeur de drogue un dealer
communique avec force gestes ces
informations un complice sur le quai
d'en face
autour de lui plusieurs vendeurs ou
acheteurs
le chef de station les connaît bien mais
avoue son impuissance
à oberkampf et saint-ambroise et le
secteur environnant en à peu près la
présence d'une centaine de dealers tous
les soirs et ça pose réellement des
problèmes de sécurité
alors oui ça en pause alors déjà pour
les voyageurs et pour les agents qui
travaillent dans ces stations qui sont
pas rassurés il ya des agressions il ya
au niveau des conducteurs y est les
coupures de courant il ya toute une gêne
en plus des agressions mais vous en tant
que chef de tazoult qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire
pas grand chose
le trafic de drogue spectacle nouveau
dans le métro cristallise toutes les
peurs des agents de la ratp beaucoup
admettent aujourd'hui que la situation
peut devenir explosive que le métro bon
mais parfois compter par une personne
n'étant c'est devenu presque des lieux
rendez vous ce n'était pas avant alors
ce qui fait que si on laissait faire
sans arrêt bon je sois déjà pré métro
aux états unis bonjour ça m'embêterait
quand même qu'en france on a eu le même
niveau que le métro new york je sentais
que maintenant il ya plus d'insécurité a
pour moi rentrant très bien ils veulent
rester anonymes
ce sont les membres de la brigade
d'intervention du métro 300 agents en
civil mais armés pour surveiller les
quelques 360 stations du réseau leur
quotidien les vendeurs de tickets à la
sauvette les marchands ambulants ou
encore les voleurs à la tire
il ya six ans lorsque je suis rentrée à
la brigade de surveillance du métro
lorsque nous interpellions un voleur à
la tire
un agresseur ces gens là avec une idée
en tête c'est de prendre la fuite
maintenant ces gens là ne prennent plus
la fuite
ils nous font face je n'ai jamais
utilisé mon arme bien qu'en depuis un an
et demi j'ai j'ai été menacé trois fois
d'un cutter
sept à huit agressions quotidiennes pour
4 million et demi de voyageurs le métro
parisien reste l'un des plus sûrs du
monde
pourtant chaque incident chaque
agression résonne un peu plus fort parmi
les agents de la ratp qui réclament des
mesures urgentes pour lutter contre
l'insécurité à roland garros plus de
gouttes de pluie que de base dans le
court aujourd'hui mais quelques
rencontres ont eu lieu quand même jean
ma mère est en ce moment les deux
français s'affrontent
thierry tulasne et jean-philippe florian
effectivement la pluie n'a pas empêché
le début de cette rencontre entre
janvier florian a tiré du lot je vous
propose d'ailleurs d'aller tout de suite
sur le central et un premier set qui se
déroule entre les deux joueurs très
serré puisque les deux joueurs en sont
en ce moment
premier set lorient mène 1 point à 0
dans ce tas dans ce tie-break jeu
décisif pour parler français diront nous
un premier set assez tendues entre le
126e joueur mondial qui est jean floc'h
lorient en fond de votre écran cela
c'est thierry tulasne que vous découvrez
qui lui et 2 100e joueur mondial fait un
mur fait amusant au plus tôt grave pour
thierry tulasne alors qu'il servait pour
le set il a perdu son service il venait
juste auparavant de prendre le service
de son adversaire
une partie je dirais de joueur de fond
de court ses classiques pour thierry
tulasne florian sait qu'il joue gros ce
soir sur ce central et lille visite peut
être à lâcher ses coups et a lâché
vraiment son jeu il monte parfois au
filet mais c'est jusqu'à présent lui qui
s'est montré le plus offensif des deux
joueurs
thierry tulasne et tendue également il
sait qu'il a fait un bon premier
parcours de roland garros est que pour
la première fois de sa vie pourrait se
qualifier pour les huitièmes de finale
alors c'est important et pour l'instant
aucun des deux joueurs n'a vraiment je
dirais qu'ils achètent et ping s'est
véritablement décontracté sur ce central
quoi qu'il en soit ce parti ne se
terminera pas ce soir elles devraient
cesser aux environs de 21h30 et une
heure de jeu encore et la partie n'est
sans doute pas terminée et il alors de
toute façon la pluie a empêché beaucoup
de rencontres
aujourd'hui steffi graf s'est quand même
qualifié très rapidement ce matin louis
steffi graf en moins d'une heure s'est
qualifiée il ya eu malheureusement
l'élimination chez les féminines de la
française sophie amiach victoire d'agen
nord l'haïtien de bordeaux qui a éliminé
la tête de série numéro 7 team mayotte
l'américain quant à boris becker en lui
entre les gouttes hisser qualifiante set
assez facilement et burger aussi jay
baer guerre l'américain qui sera le
prochain adversaire d'ailleurs de
floriane de florian ou de tulane selon
le vainqueur alors comment est ce que
philippe chatrier les organisateurs vont
faire pour rattraper le retard a posé
par la pluie alors pour l'instant précis
ne rien n'est trop grave
bon il ya quand même quelques rencontres
qui ont pu se terminer la rencontre
agenor mayotte était en rattrapage la
journée d'hier ils ne se dira masqué
duré 23 heures les rencontres vont être
reportées demain le je dirais que les
organisateurs se donnent à peu près 24
en avance à chaque fois donc il a plus
aujourd'hui
rien est encore trop grave cela
deviendrait beaucoup plus inquiétant si
demain la plus persister alors laurent
cabrol vous dira tout à l'heure s'il
faut s'il pleuvra demain à roland garros
mais je vous propose de retourner
brièvement à pékin à pékin où il est
donc maintenant 2h30 du matin l'armée
approche en ce moment de la place
tienanmen d'après les dernières dépêches
de l' agence france-presse
les hommes des dizaines de milliers de
soldats marche au pas de course vers la
place et il semble que la population a
érigé des barricades aux alentours de la
place en utilisant les barrières
destinées à juguler la circulation
depuis hier près de deux cent mille
hommes de troupes avaient été massées
près de la capitale chinoise
je vous rappelle que sur la place même
depuis quelques heures des centaines de
milliers de manifestants sont à nouveau
groupe et pour soutenir la grève de la
faim de quatre protestataires qui
proteste donc contre la loi martiale et
contre le régime chinois
tout à l'heure dans notre dernier
journal nous vous donnerons bien sûr les
toutes dernières informations en
provenance de pékin où se trouve
toujours notre envoyé spécial
bruno le bref demain encore si vous
aimez le rock rendez vous demain soir
sur antenne 2 à 23h45 avec thierry
ardisson et ses lunettes noires pour la
retransmission des récompenses décernées
à new york par l'académie du rock au
programme qui switch se dévide bowie et
d'autres gloires du rock contemporain
demain soir donc à 23h45 très vite
encore les pronostics de pierrette brès
pour le tiercé quarté + demain à auteuil
le 11 le 5 le 15 le 2 le 3 e 1 le 16 et
lui voilà maintenant c'est au tour de
laurent cabrol de vous parler du temps
de demain dans un instant pour
l'information pendant le week-end vous
avez rendez vous avec daniel bilalian
est aussi philippe gassot voilà très bon
week-end sur an plus tôt